[Music]
a massive
asteroid just hit earth right in the
middle of the atlantic ocean
thanks to nasa's new infrared telescope
we were able to detect it and prepare
for the collision
but our problems are not over yet
because now we have a hyper cane
coming our way wait what's a hyper game
how could it be worse than an asteroid
collision
and could it wipe out life across the
planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a hyper cane formed in the atlantic
ocean
66 million years ago an asteroid struck
earth
causing the extinction of the dinosaurs
but scientists have struggled to
understand
how the asteroids impact in one spot
could cause the death of a species
worldwide
in 1995 mit lecturer dr
carrie emanuel proposed that the missing
link
could be a hyper cane this massive
dangerous storm would have the power to
inject vast amounts of water
and aerosols into the atmosphere
changing its chemistry and damaging the
ozone layer
this would make the environment and
climate unsuitable for life
but could a hypercane be worse than the
hurricanes were used to
would it be possible for us to survive a
hyper cane
we'll get to that a bit later but let's
start from the beginning
a regular hurricane needs warm ocean
waters
and some kind of disturbance in the
atmosphere
think 26 degrees celsius for at least
45 meters below the surface and
lots of wind this creates enough
energy to speed up the water's cycle of
evaporating
rising cooling and condensing into
thunderstorm clouds the more the water
evaporates
the faster the winds become forming
a swirling storm the saphir simpson
scale
categorizes hurricanes based on their
speed
it starts with a category 1 hurricane
which ranges from
119 to 153 kilometers per hour
and goes up to a category 5
with wind speeds of 251 kilometers per
hour
or stronger to give you an idea
of how bad that is hurricane katrina
one of the deadliest in history was a
category 5 hurricane
it struck the united states gulf coast
with winds
of around 280 kilometers per hour
leaving almost 2 000 people dead
and it came with a heavy price tag
it caused more than 125
billion dollars in damages and
a hyper cane would be at least
four times worse than that
according to dr emmanuel's theory it
could have wind speeds
of up to get this 804 kilometers per
hour
and the size would be almost 50
kilometers tall
and 4 000 kilometers wide
that's nearly as large as the united
states
so how could this happen
well time to go back to that asteroid if
an
asteroid 12 kilometers wide which
is as big as the one that killed the
dinosaurs struck the middle of the
atlantic ocean
it would heat the water up to 50 degrees
celsius
that amount of energy could form a
hypercane in less than
48 hours so
brace yourself if the asteroid caught us
off guard and there were planes in the
air
the hyper cane could throw them off
course as it formed
pilots would need to hold on tight as
they struggled through
extreme turbulence to find a place to
land
for you on land unless you had an
underground shelter it would be nearly
impossible to survive and
even if you did have a shelter or were
far
away from the storm you'd better have an
indoor
farm set up and enough power to last for
years to come
earth as we know it would be destroyed
the protective ozone layer that shields
us from
radiation would probably be gone too
if you dared to step outside you'd need
to be
fully covered otherwise you could
develop skin cancer
but that's the least of your problems
the intensity of the sun's radiation
would make
photosynthesis impossible for smaller
plants
without this process of converting light
energy
into the chemical energy that fuels
growth
they would eventually die the food chain
would then collapse herbivores would
starve and
even though other animals could feed off
their bodies for
some time the food supply would
eventually end
luckily hyper canes don't look to be
happening
anywhere in the near future although
there were
more than 19 000 near-earth asteroids as
of 2019
with an average of 30 discoveries every
week
scientists are doing a good job
monitoring
threats to our planet however
researchers agree
that hurricanes will continue to get
stronger and more deadly primarily due
to climate change
so it might be a good idea to start
preparing for those
how about coming up with a plan to nuke
a hurricane
that sounds like a story for another
what if you